what Millions have seen Kevin Spacey
star on screen and Stage the first
alleged victim to give evidence in the
trial against him said watching the
a-lister ACT makes him feel sick Spacey
once again arriving hours before he was
needed in court and described as being
slippery snakey a predator
the alleged victim a driver who
encountered the Oscar winner on a number
of occasions in the early 2000s said
Spacey would always sit in the front of
the car and was very touchy-feely
recalling 12 occasions when he started
to grab me and grape me there were
incidents where he'd grab my hand and
put it on him then he'd laugh it off
every time I said no he'd leave it a
month and start again
dropping him off at a Showbiz party once
he said Spacey had had a couple of
drinks and was quite fired up he grabbed
me so hard I almost came off the road I
pulled over and said don't do it again
or I'll knock you out he laughed and
said it was a turn on he said come on
let's go to the party don't be silly the
jury hearing how the man told police I
used to call him a weirdo he used to
laugh about it he wasn't embarrassed a
couple of weeks would go by and he'd do
it again
the alleged victim said it left him
feeling so anxious that he struggled
sleeping and felt that he couldn't
confide in anyone because they wouldn't
understand and when lawyers for Spacey
put it to him that perhaps he might have
struggled to process what they described
as his complicated and confusing
feelings about that time he said no
nothing happened between us he was
assaulting me
Spacey vehemently denies the allegations
made against him by four men his lawyers
previously saying that the actor Will in
his evidence explain how many of the
incidents have been reimagined with a
Sinister spin Katie Spencer Sky News